i am a 38 year old man
yeah should i watch lizzie mcguire and
if so why well
absolutely brian you should you should
yeah let a man talk about it that's
right please man give me a moment
brian
nina
can you tell us about some hidden gems
on disney plus that you think everyone
should watch
i sure can brian uh so as a child of
the 90s and early 2000s i did watch a
lot of disney channel original content i
was definitely the market for many of
their shows
and when disney plus first released
rather than going to the marvel catalog
rather than watch reliving you know the
great animated classics of disney i went
directly for lizzie mcguire
without stopping i did not pass go i did
not collect two hundred dollars i went
directly for lizzie mcguire because
that's a show that i grew up on and i
wanted to be her and something i
probably shouldn't admit on looper.com
is that instead of seeing the first
x-men movie i saw the liz mcguire movie
instead
if that's a fireable offense i'll take
it
but
yeah so for the uninitiated lizzie
mcguire was the first outing of hillary
duff who is still acting still
doing pretty well she just finished a i
believe seven season run on younger
which was a pretty decent tv show
created by darren starr who created sex
in the city
and emily
yep she was the co-lead alongside sutton
foster and
molly bernard and peter herman and
several other very very talented people
so
uh yeah lizzie mcguire was her first
foray into acting i think she was like
picked from relative obscurity to play
the part and it's your average teenage
girl show but it has the twist of her
having a cartoon version of herself who
looks
just nothing like her at all like not
the same haircut
facial like likeness is really off but
you're just like okay that's lizzy's
brain that's fine and it just acts out
like the day-to-day stuff and
the first episode i return to is
the infamous one where lizzy wants her
first bra and screams i want a bra very
loudly and then it turns into slow
motion it's a masterpiece should have
won several oscars that year
um
i'm taking this one step further
so
it's a really like i went back and i
tried to watch some of it and it's
really like very of its time um
especially for girls you're like oh i
would definitely owned all those like
really ugly
low-rise jeans and butterfly clips and
glittery t-shirts but
and the the way it's shot is really
jarring there's way too much slow motion
there's slow motion in like every single
episode like five to six times in like
25 minutes
now
can i interrupt you for a second you
absolutely can i'm really just talking
about lizzie mcguire
i just that's my question right like i'm
you know you and i there is an age gap
between us
i am a 38 year old man
yeah should i watch lizzie mcguire and
if so why well what am i going to do
absolutely brian you should you should
should
yeah let a man talk about it that's
right please man
give me a moment
brian
start a new twitter account call it
brian watches lizzie mcguire honestly
bathe in the adoration of a thousand
people that you did not hope existed
i think you're going to do very well
with this
well in all seriousness in all
seriousness you should watch it because
uh hillary duff is still acting and it's
nice to see where her roots came from
especially if you're planning on
watching how i met your father which
which just recently started filming
right well i have a i have a chaser for
you that pairs perfectly with liz
mcguire and it's a disney channel
original movie called cadet kelly which
is kind of a spin-off of private
benjamin where a girly girl goes to
military school
and the reason you should watch that is
because in the years since its release
it has become like a favorite among the
lgbtq community because the sexual
tension between hillary duff and christy
carlson romano is palpable
so it remains relevant today because you
could really read it as a young girl
discovering who she is in a military
academy with a lot of ribbon dancing
nina i'm i'm not sure i'm gonna stand by
this
quite convinced me but i am more
intrigued than i was before we started i
knew that i knew you'd at least be
intrigued i didn't think i'd get to
convince that's fine i've done what i
came here to do
that's fair tom if you don't want to
watch ribbon dancing i just can't help
you i mean i do want to watch ribbon
dancing i think we all want to watch
ribbon yeah yeah have you not read his
twitter account brian watches ribbon
dancing
no i must have missed that one
nina
lizzie mcguire and you'll forgive me
because i i was the right age but i
guess just not the right demographic to
ever sure definitely not the right
demographic yeah uh
how does the having a cartoon version of
herself with body dysmorphia like how
does that affect the the
the plot or the w what does that do for
her it's it basically serves the place
of narration so instead of her talking
over every scene
it's like this is what her brain is
doing and it you know okay it's full of
high jinks in there sounds like a
herman's head situation anyone kind of
remember that
absolutely you know what lizzie mcguire
is the being john malkovich of the
disney channel
okay all right you know what
now i'm sold i didn't think of that
earlier i thought of it just now and i i
i stand by it
i will be watching lizzie mcguire
tonight i'm ready i knew it okay you got
us to watch you guys watch bluey the
other day so
speaking of which
my pick for hidden gems on disney
channel uh disney plus that you should
watch i have two picks one of them is
bluey now
i am a parent of a two-year-old who
loves the bluey theme song and tolerates
the show that follows it
but um so this is a show about a family
of blue two of them are blue dogs two of
them are i guess orange or brown they're
a family of dogs they live in australia
they are otherwise normal human beings
except they are dogs um they walk on two
feet right they walk on two legs and
they do all the two legs rather yeah
suburban australianites do australians i
guess i should say australia yeah it's
australian
not a thing yeah not the preferred term
it's the only weakness of australia man
australian night no so this show is
about it's about this little kid bluey
and her little sister bingo and they go
on advent they don't even go on
adventures they just exist and do things
that little children do and their
parents do things with them and it's
adorable and it's also genuinely funny
like it's a really well-made show each
episode's about eight minutes long and
even if you don't have if you have kids
you should watch it with your kids if
you don't have kids
you should still watch it because it's
genuinely entertaining it has made me
laugh out loud several times i just it's
just really really well done and i like
it a lot it's good stuff it's good
television so anyway that was one pick
yeah that was that was pick one that was
pick one the other one is similarly um
somewhat out of left field it's it's
just called mickey mouse
and it's they're they're short cartoons
now okay so here's the thing who's
mickey mouse you're gonna have to start
at the beginning just give us like a
shut up so mickey mouse obviously is one
of the most well-known characters in the
entire world uh it is the disney mascot
um i'll say this too for the first 38
years of my life i have always thought
that mickey mouse sucks a lot like
mickey mouse sucks like yeah if you're
given the choice between watching a
mickey mouse cartoon or a bugs bunny
cartoon you watch bugs bunny that's just
what obviously
bugs bunny is fun and cool and crafty
and he likes to
uh do violence on people and it's
wonderful um
mickey mouse by contrast is lame and
boring and he just sucks however
there are a series of shorts that were
made probably within the last seven or
eight years that are all on disney plus
they're like three to five minutes long
each
and they're deranged they're so funny
they're so good mickey mouse and donald
duck and goofy and minnie mouse and
everyone they're all doing these strange
adventures
and they are
they're just crazy there's one there's
one episode where mickey is uh he's
gonna order a new fish tank for his
beloved fish and a cat comes in breaks
the tank and then things happen and at
one point the fish is pan-fried at one
point the fish is devoured by the cat
the fish is dying it's very funny i'm
not selling it now but i guarantee that
if you watch the first couple ones and
you don't laugh there's something wrong
with you they're so sweet well you're
painting a really grim picture of it so
well that's gonna the
that's the whole thing it's not it's not
your granddad's mickey mouse it's the
sex schneider cut of yeah
schneiderlin
it's on four by three
all i can say is that it says the f word
those are my picks bluey a show for
children and mickey mouse shorts also
for children
i'm almost 40. tom
what's up mickey mouse shorts on disney
plus i wear them every weekend yes there
it is uh tom what's a disney plus hidden
gem that we should watch
i've prepared a statement oh no
[Music]
i'm so nervous about whatever is coming
please let me finish
if you and your pups are looking for an
hour and 29 minutes of grade a family
fun look no further than beverly hills
chihuahua 3 viva la fiesta in this fun
for the whole family adventure poppy
chloe and their litter of putts trade
their socal setup for life at a swanky
high-end hotel but when the littlest pup
rosa doesn't feel quite at home after
being bullied by a larger dog
[Music]
they're coming for you
[Laughter]
but when their littlest pup rosa doesn't
feel quite at home after being bullied
by a larger dog it's up to the whole
posse
of lovable mutts to throw her a king say
that she'll never forget
featuring the voices of george lopez
jake busey
and the osmond kid that isn't haley joel
beverly hills chihuahua three viva la
fiesta is a pup-lifting story
so good
you'll never want to press pause
brian ornadorf of blueray.com that the
film
said of the film parents won't feel
battered by relentless stupidity
sandy angelo chen of common sense media
called it entertaining talking dog three
quill
in a six out of ten star review james
plath
of movie metropolis gushed if you liked
beverly hills chihuahua you'll like this
second sequel more than the first it
felt like the filmmakers just tried
harder this time around
[Music]
cool
the fuzzy fun doesn't stop in sunny
california
[Laughter]
for even more cuddly excitement check
out 2013's super buddies
this seventh and final installment in
the air buddies franchise sees america's
favorite cadre of huggable golden
retrievers gifted with abilities beyond
the scope of mortal understanding thanks
to a collection of mystical rings from
the planet inspiron
taking new personas as superheroes the
buddies learned that with great power
comes great responsibility
featuring the voices of kid favorites
john ratzenberger and tim conway as well
as john michael higgins colin hanks and
zendaya
it's positively outstanding
cool
is that it
looking for something a little more
fishy yeah that's it
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
episode